[Music]
surprise blake lively is pregnant she's
expecting baby number four with hubby
ryan reynolds my family is my priority
and um my work
fits in in and around that and i'm
fortunate to have a job where i can take
my family with me and i can
tailor that
um but um but i i hope that my girls
always feel what a priority they are and
see that they can be
professional strong powerful women she
revealed her baby bump at the 10th
annual forbes power women's summit in
new york city it's important to stand up
for what you believe in and it's also
important to surround yourself with
people who
feel like they have a voice blake
sported a gold sequin dress accessorized
with a white ribbon and matching heels
sometimes you're hiding things sometimes
you're not hiding things whether it's
some extra cellulite or or a child
you either show it or you hide it now
this is actually a surprise baby bump
reveal number two for blake
back in 2019 she shocked vance when she
popped up popping out at the detective
pikachu premiere then she was expecting
the couple's third child betty i love
babies brian and blake are also dad and
mom to two more daughters james and inez
who fans caught a rare glimpse of at
ryan's walk of fame ceremony in 2016. it
looks like james might be getting into
showbiz or she looks antsy to get into
chauvin i don't know about that no
there'll be no showbiz in her future
unless she's until she's 30 i think
she's that's a safe time for her to
enter the end of the game what does it
mean to have blake the two girls here um
oh it's everything i mean just not not
only just at my family here but this is
like this only happens once in a
lifetime and and um you know normally we
don't trot the whole family out like
this but uh but i just thought i would
regret this in 20 years if i didn't have
my kids here as well so so we all we i
decided to collectively just come down
here in one big movement and be a part
of this yeah sorry ryan it's safe to say
their three young daughters are already
in showbiz well sort of family friend
taylor swift has a habit of name
checking the girls in her songs
[Music]
but back to blake and ryan they've been
total relationship goals since getting
married in 2012 after meeting on the set
of 2011's green lantern
[Music]
you said that blake turned you into the
father you always dreamed of can you
explain what that meant oh it's just i
think you never know that's a tricky
thing you never know what it's going to
be like until you're there you know and
i i have a partner that i love and and
trust and and and and she doesn't me and
i think we just help each other be
better at it we have fun we're best
friends congratulations to blake and
ryan on baby number four
[Music]
you